[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos sobre la nueva epidemia de
ébola que están anunciando varios países
de áfrica entre ellos guinea nos
acompaña carlos del río epidemiólogo y
profesor de medicina y salud pública en
la universidad emory en atlanta eeuu
gracias por estar con nosotros doctor
áfrica occidental- fue el centro de esta
epidemia entre 2003 y 2016 porque
aparece nuevamente esta epidemia de
burla y qué pasa con los sistemas de
salud en ese continente
bueno el ébola con frecuencia regresa es
una infección que no se ha ido es una
enfermedad que llamamos son ópticas
decir están animales y de animales pasa
humanos y siempre sencillamente la
interacción continua tenemos los humanos
con los animales hace que esta epidemia
que está enfermedad continúe regresando
y no nos erradica si no viene viene una
y otra vez y otra vez ahora y la vacuna
es eficaz contra esta enfermedad qué
pasa con esta vacuna para que no sea lo
mejor tan mortal y no se propague con
tanta rapidez efectivamente hay
vacunación muy eficaz contra bola y es
una oportunidad que tenemos del poder de
parar el brote utilizando una vacuna
se conoce la tasa de supervivencia ante
el ébola cuántas personas pueden
sobrevivir o si es una enfermedad
completamente mortal bueno lo que
sabíamos era que una enfermedad con una
alta mortalidad pero eso depende del
sistema de salud que usted tenga cuando
tenemos buena atención médica cuando
tenemos la atención médica necesaria la
sobrevivencia es muy buena es es ser
canal al 100%
doctor cómo hacer para entonces
fortalecer el sistema de salud en áfrica
a lo mejor puede ser con ayuda
occidental para evitar esta propagación
bueno existe hay necesidad de hacer
varias cosas la vigilancia
epidemiológica es importante pero
también es muy importante como usted lo
menciona fortalecer los sistemas de
salud y el que tengamos sistemas de
salud tan frágiles en áfrica es una de
las razones de que la mortalidad del
ébola sea tan alta ahora cuáles son los
síntomas y cómo se propaga el ébola
bueno principalmente la preparación es a
través de sangre y secreciones de una
persona infectada hacia otros y los
síntomas más importantes pues son fiebre
son malestar y posteriormente a
planificaciones hemorrágicas ahora
podría extenderse a otros continentes
como alomejor europa por su proximidad
bueno el ébola no se extiende por si
solos y requiere que una persona esté
viajando yo en este momento debido a la
comida y tampoco los viajeros que yo
creo que hay poco probabilidad que eso
ocurra y en relación a la pandemia que
estamos viendo descubrí 19 y esta
enfermedad la enfermedad del ébola
porque con el coi 19 si se pudo tener
una vacuna medianamente temprana en
menos de un año ya se están haciendo
todos los procesos de vacunación en el
mundo contra coke 19 y qué pasa con el
ébola porque dejar esta enfermedad de un
lado cuando también es una enfermedad
peligrosa y mortal no de hecho ahí ya
había una vacuna contra el ébola antes
de que hubiera una vacuna contra el
comida y de hecho la tecnología de
hernia mensajero que se utilizó para
para cubrir se hizo en base a lo que se
había hecho para de volar
claro pero pero porque a lo mejor no
buscar otros mecanismos para poder
controlar más esta enfermedad del ébola
digamos que sin duda alguna hay muchas
otras investigaciones están llevando a
cabo y que están pudiendo dar los
resultados como el desarrollo de
actividades el red de seguir que estamos
utilizando contra contra kobe fue
inicialmente desarrollado para bola
y doctor a qué población ataca más esta
enfermedad digamos los rangos de edad
bueno en realidad puede ser a cualquier
persona la situación es que la quien se
infecta y se puede infectar con más
frecuencia persona que está cuidando
enfermos entonces es un problema serio
en personal de salud doctor muchísimas
gracias por su tiempo y por estar aquí
con nosotros en esta sección de france
24 de cinco minutos con estábamos
conversando con el doctor carlos del río
pedido me obligó profesor de medicina de
salud pública en la universidad emory en
atlanta en eeuu a ustedes también por
supuesto gracias por acompañarnos en
cinco minutos y hasta una próxima
oportunidad feliz día
[Música]